[Applause]
thank you very much all right please we
got an amazing show so shut
up I know I love you
too but uh there's a lot to talk about
today Congress is in
chaos no it's not a repeat I mean and
that could be any show but you saw heard
what happened the speaker of the house
got
canned this has never
happened yes uh Kevin MC was he's from
California he was the Speaker of the
House the Republic got rid of him well
actually he made a deal with the
Democrats to keep the government open uh
and then they fired
him this guy has more knives in his back
than Britney
Spears what they just they make little
jokes
here now but McCarthy's big sin of
course was working with the Democrats to
keep the government open which
Republicans felt was dangerously close
to governing
but you know he is second in line do you
know that the speaker of the house
that's no
biggie but that's how it works president
vice president check with Matt
Gates that's
our
so okay so now they're looking for the
new speaker uh lot of Republicans
throwing their hat in the ring Jim
Jordan do you know this guy
former wrestling
coach the perfect preparation for
government
work and also famous because he never
wears a
jacket that's
his uh Bob Menendez heard that he said
where do you keep your gold
bars
uh but we I mean we don't know if it's
going to be Republicans don't know who
they want they don't care as long as
they own the
libs and the Democrats they don't care
who it is as long as it's a black
lesbian oh we make little jokes please
but uh no the really big story this week
the the substantial story is that even
Biden now is admitting that the migrant
crisis is real he said today it
build the
wall I'm I I thought I was getting
punked I I well you know there's an
election coming up and he's got a move
to the center it was either that or
shoot up a case of Bud
Light
uh but a lot of the Democrats actually
feel betrayed by this because it does go
against his campaign promises I mean
they said we know it's in our platform
that it says secure the Border but we
didn't think you'd actually do something
about
it